after watching good to be bad we've come
up with some new and exciting theories
that just might surprise you keep
watching to find out which lady of the
court might prove herself to be a wicked
warrior now let's jump right into what
we think will happen once the BK's
announce who the new wave of villain
kids are and uprising the announcer dude
in the VK day teaser said that mal and
her friends would be choosing for
villain kids to go to our don prep on VK
day but why only four and why is it only
if two mal Evie Carlos and J it seems
like a recipe for a lot of
disappointment we can see that there are
a ton of kids applying for a shot to
leave the aisle and go to our dine when
only four kids get to go there is going
to be some major storm of resentment all
across the aisle this will give Mouse
enemies like uma and her crew a lot of
power over the disgruntled villain kids
who are left on the Isle and from what
we've seen in other trailers that's the
last thing mal needs right now
this could wind up creating an uprising
and revolt of villain kids who are left
behind
the song it's good to be bad it's a
power dam that encourages kids to
celebrate who they are and where they
come from but the message seems to be a
bit mixed they are telling the vks to
embrace their roots but only selecting
four of them to have the opportunity to
rise up and create a better life
maskings about how everybody wants to be
like them that's kind of rubbing it in
for the majority of the VK population
since so if you were going to be able to
get off the isle so who will go and who
will stay let's take a closer look Celia
in the good to be bad video mal visits
Celia at her fortune-telling booth to
encourage her to apply for a spot Edoras
on Celia seems like a good kid with a
lot of promise but we know from past
trailers that she for tells a pretty
dark prophecy about the fate of mal Evie
Carlos and Jay
[Music]
so we'll sylia be selected as one of the
four lucky villain kids getting off the
isle or will she be back behind to fend
for herself in that dark and hopeless
place we haven't really seen her in
auradon in any of the trailers except
for the one where she is holding dude
the dog behind those armored guards so
what is this girl up to maybe she used a
bit of trickery to give her an advantage
in the VK day application process if she
gets caught cheating and that would
immediately disqualify her from going to
Oregon it's fair to say that she
probably wouldn't take it well learning
how to lose gracefully doesn't seem like
a thing mini villain parents would teach
their kids so we'll see Leah team up
with uma we know uma has a pretty major
score to settle with mal
Celia could be a useful asset to help
uma exact her revenge but just what kind
of evil plot does she have in mind
Hades we've seen Celia unlocking what
appears to be the underground prison
where Hades is locked away you shouldn't
have come and we've also seen Yuma
holding Hades ember it all goes together
somehow but how exactly well if our
theory about Celia and uma forming an
alliance is accurate it makes perfect
sense
maybe uma convinces Celia to free Hades
from his underground Jail
so he can help them infiltrate auradon
we know that Hades was able to get his
arm through that hole in the barrier and
we also heard Mao say something or
someone was draining her powers it's
likely that Hades is ember is
responsible for Mao's loss of power but
how exactly does oh my get a hold of
Hades his ember it doesn't seem like
something he would misplace or just
leave lying around
that's where Celia comes in if steely
eyes anything like her dad
dr. facile ear she's got plenty of
tricks up her sleeves maybe Celia lifted
the Ember off of Hades without him
realizing it then she could give it to
Emma and they could both get even with
mal for casting them out come to think
of it maybe uma and Celia are the ones
draining maus powers dizzy it's pretty
much a given that dizzy is going to be
one of the four BK's who gets picked to
leave the isle and go to our Don we'd
love you to join us to auradon prep we
know how much mal and evey adore her
she's responsible for the most wicked
cool hairstyles
the aisle the ladies at our Don would be
lining up around the block to get into
Dizzy's salon
we saw dizzy asleep on a couch and what
looks like a castle and our Don in the
Big Sleep trailer that's a pretty good
indicator that she made it off the aisle
and is one of the chosen ones we also
saw sneeze twin boys fast asleep on the
other side of the couch if smiie is one
of the villains on the aisle that would
make his twin boys squeaky and squirmy
villain kits from the aisle too
so if dizzy squeaky and squirmy were all
picked to leave the aisle to go to
Oregon that leaves only one spot open
so if Celia isn't the fourth who will it
be and what will the overall message of
descendants three be misfits and
warriors Sophia Carson recently gave a
pretty revealing interview about the new
descendants movie she said the thing
she's always loved so much about the
descendants films is that they stand for
much more than fairy tales
she said they stand for the outcast the
misfits and the ones who feel they don't
fit in this is something we can all
relate to because we've all felt that
way at one time or another
Sophia went on to say that descendants 3
is a beautiful and empowering story and
this is the most intriguing part of it
all Sophia's shared that the message of
this film is almost political without
giving too much away
she said the movie really reflects the
current time in which we are living she
marveled at how cathartic and beautiful
the finale is and she also revealed that
the director Kenny Ortega called Evie
the Joan of Arc of the story she alluded
that we will see more of Evie's warriors
side in the upcoming film so this lady
of the court will definitely bring her
AGame come the threequel this leads us
to even more unanswered questions about
the fate of the vks all we know for sure
is that the film promises to be bigger
and badder than the first two after
seeing that incredible opening number we
can't wait to see the rest so if the
choice was yours which V case would you
choose to bring to art on prep sound off
in the comments section and that's a
wrap to be the first to see our latest
videos be sure to subscribe to the
things and give us a big thumbs up
thanks for watching we'll see you next
time
[Music]